avant d'arriver ici sa jeep yang
n'aurais jamais pu imaginer brandir le
drapeau de la corée du sud
un jour en corée du nord on ne sait même
pas qu'un tel drapeau existe lance-t-il
johnnie walker
il a fui en 2001 par la mongolie il
affirme qu'il risquait la prison il
avait été surpris à écouter des
émissions sud-coréenne c'est interdit
grâce à une petite radio entrés
illégalement par la chine
sage et yang n'a jamais revu ses deux
frères il ajoute qu'il ne peut pas
s'inscrire aux réunions familiales
coordonnée par la croix rouge des deux
corridors anonyme parce que pyongyang
considère que tous ceux qui ont fait
défection sont des traîtres dit il
ces réunions une vingtaine depuis l'an
2000 selon la croix rouge représente
souvent la chance d'une vie pour
retrouver par exemple
après des décennies une soeur qui était
resté au nord dans le chaos de la guerre
de corée ou pour faire la connaissance
des enfants ni durant six longues
séparations de brèves retrouvailles les
dernières remontent à 2015 pour chaque
rencontre
le nombre de familles limités à 200 c
choisi par le sud le sont par tirage au
sort une responsable souligne que c'est
trop peu car il reste encore des
dizaines de milliers de réfugiés
nord-coréens souvent très vieux inscrits
sur les listes d'attentes esprit limited
en commun sont toutes en wheeling sur le
mur des souhaits pour qu'il y ait au
plus vite d'autres réunions
plus de 65 ans après le conflit
fratricide qui avaient dispersé des
familles la reprise de dialogue entre
les deux corées favorisée par la période
d'apaisement à l'approché des jeux
olympiques est vu comme un signe
encourageant par la croix rouge
les communications avec le nord dans le
dossier des familles étaient interrompus
depuis 2016 la présence de ces nord
coréen en corée du sud
le temps de la grand messe sportive les
jeux de la paix n'est pas nécessairement
présage de déblocage à court terme car
pyongyang exige avant toute nouvelle
réunion familiale que séoul rapatrie un
groupe de transfuges une précondition
qui semble difficile à satisfaire
ici annick bureaud radio-canada séoul